a family court judge in the Bronx is
under Fire for allegedly attempting to
have a manaja with a mother whose case
she's adjudicating according to
screenshots provided by Sydney
Sutherland the mother in question Judge
Cynthia Lopez pinged her on an app
called three fun on which the judge
describes herself as bisexual with a
partner named ant apparently the judge
and her Paramore quote love thick girls
just as much as they love petite girls
though quote at the end of the day it's
all about personality still she prefers
guys to quote be stocky and I will leave
her other anatomical preferences to the
imagination the mother purportedly
propositioned by the judge in her own
case responded quote
you know who the FI am at which
point the judge reportedly blocked her
on the app and the mother has a long
list of run-ins with the law and
reportedly claims to have been married
nine times but that doesn't excuse ACC
the judge who has since recused herself
from the case lending some credibility
to the allegations so the mother seems
nuts but the mother isn't a member of
the New York Bar she isn't a judge bad
enough for the mother to be on the
creepy threes map but a judge I don't
even care really that the judge asked
the mother out that's secondary if the
allegations are true the judge should be
disbarred just for being on the app
that's why the Bar Association
has a good moral character requirement
to practice law certainly to act as a
judge the problem is what was once
universally understood to be creepy
degeneracy is now considered by our
political Elite to be some sort of human
right if the judge were disbarred for
her side hustle soliciting threesoms she
could probably sue the bar association
for discrimination against the LGBT org
Community if the judge in the case in
that case were anything like her she
would win because the law is only as
just as the people who practice it and
that's why today our temples of Justice
more closely resemble brothel I'm
Michael nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show
welcome back to the show president Trump
is comparing himself to Elvis we'll get
to that very important news story in a
second first though you got to check out
P talk right now go to PE talk.com P
talk is making it easier and more
affordable to connect with the people
you love by giving you the same coverage
you know and love for half the price
with unlimited plans starting at just 20
bucks a month the average family saves
almost $1,000 a year P talk is helping
you beat inflation and stay connected to
your loved ones a veteran owned company
P talk raised $10 million toward
veterans debt last year alone what's
more P Talk's customer service team is
located here in the US and can help you
make the switch in as little as 10
minutes I love pure talk I've got Pure
Talk service it is the best wireless
network in the country and you can take
it overseas if you happen to be
traveling internationally it's just
phenomenal uh the customer service is
great it's very very easy to switch I
strongly recommend you to go check out
PE talk today in no small part because
they support you and me and what we
believe in go to PE talk.com to make the
switch right now our viewers will save
an additional 50% off your first month
Pur
talk.com today speaking of grievance and
hustling there's a racial Justice
Advocate who has gone viral thanks to
our friend over there at Libs of Tik Tok
she's gone viral for explaining to her
audience why showing up on time is white
supremacy as a racial Justice Advocate
I'm often invited to give talks or to do
workshops where I talk to white people
about race a big part of my practice is
to offer real life stories examples that
type of thing that help white people to
be able to identify white supremacy in
everyday life my husband's family is
white and I often use the cultural
differences between my family and his
family as a way to help white people see
their whiteness there's one example that
I use that always gets a ton of push
back my husband and I were late to our
first Thanksgiving with his family I say
late because it started at 12 we got
there at 12:10 but whenever we got there
at 12:10 everybody was already sat down
and eating I didn't know that I used
this illustration to point out that
different cultures have different
understandings of time lateness and what
it means to be polite without fail a
white person will push back and say that
lateness is impolite I always use this
as a teachable moment I usually ask a
series of pointed questions that
challenge their assumptions sometimes it
takes a lot of work but by the end
they're able to identify how white
cultural dominance Works in this one
small area of Life which opens the door
for them to start peeling in the
onion okay we've all seen this video a
million times not this exact video but
versions of this video with versions of
this woman so what's it
about why why are people being so mean
to the white people why is so now you're
saying that just showing up on time is
white supremacy why why is this woman
doing this you know why this woman's
doing
this because her white audience wants
her to that's
why really we cannot blame the black
people even the BLM activists for this
they are giving their audience what they
want who is This Woman's audience This
Woman's audience is liberal white people
her job is to go to Liberal white people
and make them feel guilty and then they
pay her money for that it's it's like a
a dominatrix who has a bunch of weirdo
clients who want her to beat beat them
up or so whip them with chains or
something that's what this is and she
gives the audience what they want the
customer is always right this woman
obviously doesn't hate white people
because This Woman's husband is white or
at the very least the H the woman's
husband was adopted by a white family
right she says my husband's family is
white which means either he's white or
he's adopted and he's and he's
culturally white either way though she's
got a lot of familiarity with with white
culture and white people and she
involves herself in them she probably
spends most of her time with white
people because the people she works with
are white and the people that she has
her romantic life with are broadly white
so it's not that she hates that she
she's maow moou the flat catchers
because they're asking her to that's
what this is really
about th this is about a masochistic
perversion and you know we talk a lot
about perversions in our culture because
we live in a very perverted and decadent
time but this is just another example of
it this is just another example of
people Desiring something that is
harmful to them ultimately bad for them
but they want it anyway just like
someone who's a bit fat wants more candy
bars than than he ought to have just
like uh someone who is sexually decadent
wants all sorts of uh sterile and
hedonistic
sexual activities uh so too with the
racial grievance this this is entirely
about masochistic white if the white
people stopped being masochistic if the
white liberals stopped feeling guilty
for the color of their skin this whole
industry would disappear overnight all
of the BLM stuff all the George it would
disappear
overnight but it's still here because
the audience wants it okay so we focused
on the really important news stories now
let's focus on a much less newsworthy
news item the United States is bombing
Iraq and
Syria I almost didn't even include it in
the show because it's like a day that
ends in why of yeah we're bombing of
course we're bombing Iraq and Syria
every every US president has to bomb
Iraq and
Syria for my entire life every single US
president has bombed Iraq or Syria they
they've all bombed Iraq with maybe the
exception of trump I know Trump bombed
Syria I don't I guess he probably bombed
Iraq right when he was wiping out Isis
they all George HW Bush Clinton Bush to
Obama Trump
Biden so okay we're bombing Iraq and
Syria why are we bombing Iraq and Syria
because we want to hit Iran but we don't
really want to hit Iran but we kind of
want to hit Iran so this is according to
centcom the US Central Command at 4 pm.
Eastern February 2nd us Central Command
forces conducted air strikes in Iraq and
Syria against Iran's Islamic
revolutionary guard Corps cuds force and
Affiliated militia groups US military
forces struck more than 85 targets with
numerous aircraft to include long-range
bombers flowing from the US we deployed
more than 125 Precision Munitions the
facilities that were struck included
command and control Ops centers uh Intel
centers Rockets missiles unmanned aerial
vehicle storages the list goes on and on
okay I guess that's fine because Iran's
proxies attacked a US base and killed
three US troops and injured many more
and we know that iran-backed uh
terrorists have been targeting us ships
and trying to shut down trade so we're
going to strike them back okay in I I
really don't want to go to war with Iran
but in principle I understand the notion
of of retaliating here establishing
deterrence the problem is this this
doesn't do that we told Iran we were
going to do this ahead of time we said
yeah we don't really want to kill any of
your guys we just we just want to you
know take out some of the munitions we
need to retaliate somehow you know it's
look we'll start giving you pallets of
cash again soon but we're looking pretty
bad here and it's an election year so
can you just is it cool it's going to be
this time and here so make sure you
evacuate and get all your stuff that you
need to pack up you know we'll give you
a few days and then we're going to hit
it is that okay Ayatollah is that fine
it's just so pathetic
because it's the worst possible strategy
Trump was basically a dove except when
he would just blow things up randomly
Trump Trump did not want war he was very
reluctant to use military force and then
he would take out Iran's top General and
everyone would just be on edge every all
of our enemies would just think you know
I'm gonna hold off for a little bit even
Putin Putin probably figured there was a
95% chance Trump would not do anything
but Trump reportedly told Putin hey look
if you further invade Ukraine I'm going
to blow up Moscow and I'm sure Putin was
thinking ah he's probably bluffing he
probably but 5% chance do you really
want to take it no the Trump policy was
largely the Reagan policy which was try
not to get involved too much overseas
try not to use military force but have a
a a credible
deterrence in other words speak softly
and carry a big stick in other words be
peaceful but have a credible threat of
violence and what Biden has done here is
exactly the opposite it's both weak and
belligerent somehow it's just it's just
so perfectly wrong will not achieve its
objectives and if if anything it will
probably just escalate the chance for
more war maybe that's what the Democrats
want who knows you know what I want good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use code nolles
February is the month of
love and everybody loves free bacon when
you subscribe to any of good ranchers
100% American Meat boxes they will add
one and a half pounds of Apple Woods
smoked bacon to your order for free for
a year good ranchers sources all of
their meat from from local farms and
ranches in the us meaning you can trust
every bite but it's not just about taste
it's about the experiences and memories
associated with it whether it's the
mouthwatering smell in the kitchen on a
Sunday evening or the joy of sharing a
plate of bacon wrapped appetizers with
friends good ranchers has a way of
creating moments that linger in people's
hearts and taste buds you know I I love
good ranchers I love it it's my favorite
meat that I get I was gone last week I
was in LA and it was a fine trip but the
thing that I really missed my wife and
kids but also good ranchers fall in love
with beef chicken seafood especially
bacon All Over Again by subscribing at
goodranchers.com claim 240 bucks in free
bacon with my code nolles this offer is
not available on their site it's an
exclusive offer to our listeners I don't
know how they offer this quality for
this price it doesn't make any Financial
sense to me but it is just the greatest
make use of it while you can good
ranchers.com code NOS for the best bacon
in the USA goodranchers.com American
Meat delivered Valentine's Day is coming
up fast and whether you're shopping for
him or her Jeremy's is the perfect gift
to surprise your better half from
delicious chocolate to smooth razors to
the iconic leftist ears tumbler and to
celebrate Jeremy is offering a 20%
discount on all Valentine's Day bundles
that's right 20% off but you have to act
fast because today is the last day for
shipping on time for Valentine's arrival
this offer is only here for a limited
time go to Jeremy
rers.us bundle before it's gone Jeremy's
Valentine's Day Sale the best way to
treat your Valentine and to treat
yourself speaking of the Biden foreign
policy it would appear to be going from
bad to worse uh Biden's National
Security adviser Jake Sullivan has now
outlined the Biden Administration plan
for long-term peace in the Middle East
what is the end game here do you see any
Prospect at all he seems we've been
ruling it out prime minister Netanyahu
of some kind of a long-term deal that
leads to a Palestinian State well the US
position on this is very straightforward
the only long-term answer to peace in
the region to Israel's Security in the
region uh is a two-state solution with
Israel security guaranteed a Palestinian
state that also has uh security
guarantees for Israel that's what we're
going to keep working for we were doing
that before October 7th I think since
October 7th the need to work on that uh
has only increased and would like to
deliver an outcome over time that has
eluded administrations of both parties
for decades uh that is in the best
interest We Believe of everyone in the
region and in The Wider world what is
this guy talking about like I know he's
saying a lot of words and they're the
same kind of words that you read in the
New York Times and that you hear in NPR
and that I guess that you hear on ABC
News but what does this mean well
obviously the long-term solution for
peace in the Middle East is a two-state
solution in Israel Palestine yeah how
how how do you think that's going to
work Palestine the Palestinian people
for whom I have great
sympathy they feel like they're up
against a wall and so they elected a
cartoonishly evil terrorist group to be
its government and the terrorist group
in its Charter says that we're we're
going to destroy the state of Israel
there will be no state of Israel so
that's the Palestinian position now the
Israeli position is that these people
elected Hamas and and they want to
destroy the state of Israel and they're
going to keep attacking us and doing pgr
and things like that so uh we want Gaza
and frankly we want the West Bank too
that's the Israeli position they want
the whole area both groups want the
whole area okay and neither side is
willing to concede anything and neither
side believes that any concession at all
will help them it will only hurt hurt
them because the the long-term goals are
the
same so what's the two-state
solution also how how is the two-state
solution going to satisfy the
Palestinian people a two-state solution
is not going to get the Palestinians
their land back if the if the point of
view of the Palestinians is these
Israelis had no right to come in when
the UN established the state of Israel
and they took our land and we want it
back then there there's no two-state
solution that's ever going to accomplish
that also how are you going to have a
two-state solution when you got two
parts of your country separated by
another country the Gaz in the West Bank
it's just Pie in the Sky it's ridiculous
I have a great deal of Sympathy for the
Israelis I have a great deal of Sympathy
for the Palestinians actually the group
I don't have sympathy for are these
these liberal utopians who just keep
making these
stupid inclinations the these stupid um
little uh platitudes about how how
here's how we have peace in the Middle
East by giving each side nothing that
they actually want and just just putting
off an inevitable conflict again it's
just so childish it's unbelievable and
these are supposed to be the adults in
the room when Trump got elected we heard
oh this he's going to bring another war
in the Middle East oh no Trump he's
going to bring on World War III and what
happened we got the
period of greatest peace in the Middle
East in my
lifetime we got the Abraham Accords we
got the Saudi sitting down with the
Israelis who thought that was going to
happen it it was working pretty well and
but now we're back to business as usual
and business as usual is going to be
more and more war in the Middle East all
the while they tell you this is the this
is the only path to peace give me a
break now speaking of Joe Biden some
good news Joe Biden has the lowest
January approval rating of any president
in an election year ever recorded this
is according to a CNN poll Biden's
popularity is
38% that is Five Points below where
Trump was in January of 2020 and
remember we're told that Trump lost the
20 20 election remember so so by how
much more will Joe Biden lose the 2024
election right right maybe not Biden's
popularity is nine points worse than
Obama's at the same point in his tenure
so this should make us feel really good
and to some degree it
does here's the
problem I was in Los Angeles last week I
was doing a lot of episodes of the
prageru book club which will be coming
out soon and I was doing another prageru
five minute video I have a another
five-minute video that just came out
this week on president Chester Allen
Arthur one of our nation's most
underrated presidents then I went up to
Santa Barbara I did the whatever podcast
you can catch my three-hour debate with
uh some feminists it was three to one
feminists versus me on the whatever show
and that was three hours and then there
was a six-hour dating podcast so you you
going to have a week's worth of of
viewing but while I was up there I had
lunch with my friend Alan estan and he
runs prageru and he made a brilliant
point the brilliant point
was Republicans are very concerned with
getting votes so we say okay this policy
proposal this Alliance is going to help
us with this community and we're going
to win over here and this is how we're
going to perform better among the
working class in this state and blah
blah
blah Democrats are not concerned with
getting votes the democrat's priority is
getting
ballots so when the Democrats are
pushing for their election Shenanigans
it's always to destroy voter ID it's
always to increase voter registration
even potentially of non-citizens It's
Always to uh permit ballot harvesting
it's always to place ballot drop off
boxes often illegally far away from the
county clerks it's always to have
widespread maons for longer periods of
time with this that and the other thing
the Republicans are concerned with votes
the democ Democrats are concerned with
ballots guess which wins elections now
you might say okay well this time
they're not going to have CO as an
excuse sure but a lot of the the covid
quote unquote covid measures that they
put into place to rig the election last
time a lot of them were still in place
have we done anything to fix that Mark
Zuckerberg invested a ton of money into
liberal organizations that that
practically took over mailin voting
practically took over a lot of the
elections in 2020 in some in some cases
in violation of the law have we fixed
that no so I feel good about this poll
I'm glad to hear that that Biden's doing
much much worse than Trump was the year
that Biden supposedly beat Trump but is
it is it really all about the popularity
polls or is it more about ballots yeah
I'm I'm pleased to see that the GOP is
doing a lot more this time around for
get out the vote efforts tpusa action
has has been working very hard Charlie
Kirk's been working very hard to uh
increase turnout among conservatives but
we still have that fundamental
distinction that Allan pointed out very
very
wisely votes and ballots what are we
going to do to get those ballots or or
more to the point to keep the
Democrats from having control over them
speaking of
trump a lot of people are scratching
their heads over a trump truth social
post that came out yesterday and it was
a it was a picture half the screen is
Elvis Presley and half the screen is
Donald
Trump and uh the tweet it says
uh lots of people have said that I look
a lot like
Elvis for so many years many people have
been saying that what do you
think people are scratching what what is
he even talking about this is
Beyond policy this is my favorite part
of Trump's political style because this
kind of a
post is funny it's weird and it's
totally
disarming the the libs have to respond
to it it drives them crazy they have to
call him an idiot and they have to call
him distracted but the thing that the
libs are most upset about when it comes
to these sorts of posts and Trump makes
them all the time is that it it makes it
much harder for them to portray Trump as
Hitler this
levity this this kind of
bizarre little show it makes it very
hard Hitler doesn't make a post like
that Hitler never does the picture where
it's half Hitler half Elvis or half I
don't know I don't know who the singer
would be in those days half
um I actually don't I actually don't
know who would be The Mills Brothers or
something probably not uh that doesn't
happen right Trump has this bit of
levity and it this is something that a
lot of the critics that Trump has driven
mad don't really understand is that they
see Trump as being this totally
narcissistic self-serious guy he's not
self-serious at all and even below that
level of bragado doio you know he puts
his name in Gold letters on buildings
and he talks about at gradias below that
Trump seems to me to demonstrate more
humility than most politicians I was
reminded of this when the Brett
Kavanaugh hearing was going on and
remember ju Justice Kavanaugh he was
asked about a party he went to an High
School when he was 16 or something they
said did you drink beer in high school
Justice Kavanaugh and he said I like
beer yeah I drink beer and they asked
president Trump about this and he gave
what I felt was the perfect answer I can
honestly say I never had a beer in my
life okay right it's one of my only good
traits I don't drink whenever they're
looking for something good I said I
never had a glass of alcohol I've never
had alcohol I've just you know for
whatever reason can you imagine if I had
what a mess I'd be would I be the I'd be
the world's
worst it's a great line and you hear a
lot of those kind of lines from Trump
right which I'm the greatest I'm the
smartest only I can save the country but
then you get this spit he goes look I
can say I'm probably the only President
can say I've never had beer in my life
it's the only good thing you can say
about me it's my only good trait could
you imagine if I had be here I'd be the
worst I'd be could you imagine right
that's an example of humility it's self
effacing a lot of the bragado doio is
just the New
Yorkers are better able to spot this
kind of thing from Trump I remember in
2016 when Trump came onto the scene
really as a prominent candidate and
everyone in the conservative movement
hated him Drew claven and I were two of
the only people who said I don't know
he's kind of kind he's kind of funny I
kind of like him no coincidence I think
that Drew and I both grew up in New York
and this is how New Yorkers
talk and it's it's just it's fun I like
it it the weird Elvis post it reveals
the man to be human that that post was
not written by political Consultants
okay he was probably just batting it
around one day even even if it were
written by political Consultants it it's
it's funny it's weird it's it's just
it's not the kind of thing that any
other politician posts it makes you
think this guy's human we know he writes
his own tweets back when he was on
Twitter we know he writes a lot of this
all caps the misspellings talking about
mik brzinsky face and you you might say
well that's not disciplined it's not
focused on the message yeah whatever at
least I know I'm talking to a human
being and that goes a long way in
politics and whether you love the guy or
whether you hate the guy a lot of career
politicians have tried to ape that style
in recent years
unsuccessfully that is a that is a kind
of political talent that you pretty much
cannot learn so I'm just trying to give
you a little window into Trump's
political skill and when you want a
window into your home you've got to
check out Renewal by Anderson right now
text nolles to 200 300 if your house is
feeling a little chilly right now you
might need to consider window
replacements for most homeowners window
replacement is not something they've
ever done before and it may be a bit of
a daunting task luckily there's a
company that will do the work for you
Renewal by Anderson is your One-Stop
shop for window design manufacturer and
installation Windows play a crucial role
in regulating indoor temperatures if you
notice a spike in your heating or
cooling bills it may be due to
inefficient windows don't put it off any
longer Renewal by Anderson offers
limited fully transferable and best in
the nation warranty coverage I have had
a carpenter unsolicited write to me say
Michael I heard you mention Renewal by
Anderson when I go to homes with Renewal
by Anderson it's the best work that I
ever see I have a cousin who's worked
for this company for years and has
always spoken incredibly highly of it
Renewal by Anderson right now is is
offering a free inhome consultation on
quality energy efficient Affordable
Windows or patio doors with special
financing options text nolles kws to 200
300 for a free consultation to save 375
bucks off every window 775 bucks off
every door savings won't last long be
sure to check it out text Nes K Wes to
2300 that is nlls to 2300 texting
privacy policy in terms of conditions
posted to text. us texting roles for
recurring automated text marketing
messages message data rates may apply
reply stop top. go to window appointment
now.com for full offer to
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Gary Lancaster 8612 who says I don't
blame that young woman oh this is the
woman who who was complaining about
having to work 40 hours a week and she
didn't have money for rent she didn't
have time to do anything I don't blame
that young woman for being upset she's
been promised all sorts but now is
working full-time and her post- rent
income is less than 400 bucks a month
yeah I agree I agree I I know a number
of conservatives just made fun of her
and said you know quit quit your belly
ache and snowflake you know I used I
would have to walk uphill both ways in
the snow to go to work for 400 hours a
week and what you know but I I have a
great deal of sympathy for her actually
even a degree of empathy yeah she was
promised a bunch of lies and she was
told to order her life in a certain way
that's unnatural and contrary to her
happiness and the political economy has
has also been arranged in such a way
that is contrary to the happiness of a
lot of people and I think it's fair to
recognize that that's wrong if if we
recognize if we conservatives recognize
that something about the political
status quo is not quite right then we
should be gratified when young people
are recognizing the same thing that
we're
recognizing right they're on our side
you're right we should change something
about the way the political economy is
structured now speaking of the
presidential race Nikki Haley is in a
little bit of hot water because uh
Nikki's campaign posted a couple of
pictures reportedly of of of notes that
she has received letters of
encouragement she's received so one of
them supposedly from Mary a and you can
see the picture it's on lined notebook
ruled and lined notebook paper like you
would have had in fifth grade or
something years ago I don't even know if
kids still use notebooks they probably
just use tablets and computers and it's
it's written in a font this was
obviously typed but it's supposed to be
handwritten I guess and it says I want
to encourage Nikki Haley to keep
pressing on three exclamation marks all
curiously exactly
identical because it's clearly a font we
need a competent and committed leader to
stay the course in the bid for the
presidency I'm an independent and I
voted for the best candidate every
election cycle on this year it's Nikki
then another identical exclamation point
Mary
a then the next the next note that the
Haley campaign posted is even more
embarrassing it's it's in an email box
and it says two Niki Haley subject
blank and then it says please do not
give up the fight all caps in a world
that's become crazy with Strife we need
a level-headed conservative leader to
navigate us through the insanity no one
is more capable than you are to write
the ship and heal this great nation we
need you Nikki this country needs you
our allies and The Beautiful People of
this world need you I don't want to see
you give up and I guarantee you there
are millions more out there who feel
exactly as I do Michael be and
then then you get to the bottom and you
see send button so you realize this is
not an email that one has received it's
an email that one has composed
and obviously the two Nikki haly you
know there would probably be an email
address in there and this was just
written by some campaign flag for Nikki
and it's really not only embarrassing
but it's really really transparent now
they're trying to do damage control and
they're they're posting pictures and
screenshots that that at least looks
somewhat more legitimate but really
sad I've said from the beginning Nikki
Haley is a very skilled politician look
she's made it to the last person in the
race other than Donald Trump and she was
successful as the governor of South
Carolina and then she was pretty
Centrist there more from the liberal
side of the Republican party and then
she ends up working as Trump's un
Ambassador she's very popular in that
role including among the conservative
side of the party then she leaves and
Trump said nice things about her and
then she turned on Trump then she
embraced Trump against then she turned
on him and she's very skilled at it she
it's it takes a very good politician to
be able to do all of that her campaign
is not very skilled I'm afraid and I I
don't even know that this is entirely
their fault or her fault Nikki Haley is
going to have a an increasingly
difficult time attracting good campaign
talent because there is no path for her
to win the
presidency even a lightning bolt from a
Democrat or from the sky against Donald
Trump still would not give her the
nomination because the RNC would
probably just give it to someone else
who's more from the Trump side of the
party not from the Nikki Haley side of
the party she's made herself by running
in the only lane that was available to
her she's made herself the candidate of
a minority of
Republicans so even even you know Trump
God forbid falling out of this race uh
it wouldn't give her the nomination now
I I still think there's a good argument
for her to continue to run it puts her
it makes her the leader of the liberal
or establishment wing of the party which
is something makes her essentially
George HW Bush in 1980 it uh gives her I
know little razor speaking fees it'll
get her a bigger book Advance it will
give her some more influence in politics
it'll probably get her on the board of
more companies and so there there's
plenty of reason for her to stay in
she's still got money and as a wise
political friend told
me the only reason that presidential
campaigns ever end is because they ran
out of money and she still got money she
got that Cook network money so she'll
stay in for a while but there's not much
reason for campaign workers to support
her bid other other than to just get a
quick Buck but you don't work on a
political campaign to make money because
there's actually not that much money in
it some of the TV Consultants can make
some money but really the reason that
you work hard on a presidential campaign
is so that you can get an appointment
once the person becomes president or
vice president or cabinet secretary and
that's just not going to happen here so
expect more more errors from the Haley
campaign it's just kind of in the cards
okay speaking of women JK rling the
author of Harry Potter has been accused
of and a teacher just gave a master
class in how to handle that kind of
accusation this from one of his students
WEA treat this as a thought experiment
I'm not going to say what's right or
wrong or what way to think the whole
point is to learn how to think not what
to think yeah so when you say big you
you're you're starting with the
conclusion that given her bigoted
opinions so first let's start with does
she she have bigoted opinions so when
when you say bigoted opinions she has
had a history of being extremely
transphobic I've heard you've heard so
what can you give me an example in 2019
she said dress however you please call
yourself whatever you like sleep with
any consenting adult who will have you
um live your best life in peace and
security but Force women out of their
jobs for starting that for stating that
sex is real so you find that bigoted
what do you find about it there it was
deemed
transphobic like I myself do you find
that transphobic yourself uh I don't
really have an opinion on it but I'm
just going with what a lot of other
people have said so let's pause it let's
not go with what other people are saying
let's try and learn how to critically
think so let's analyze the Tweet
ourselves so that statement do you see
anything problematic disregarding other
people people's opinions is that
transphobic to you
so to me no like you said at the
beginning of this conversation you said
given the fact that JK Rowling is
transphobic how do you feel about Harry
Potter now retroactively looking at that
statement do you think that that was the
best way to phrase no I feel like an
idiot now beautiful beautifully done the
whole video is much longer it's four
four and a half minutes worth taking a
look it's very simple what he does
though
what this teacher does is what all of us
should do when we're speaking to people
who are just totally programmed by the
liberal
establishment and that's to ask why do
you think that well everybody knows that
oh I don't I'm maybe I'm a dumb maybe
I'm a little bit stupid what why do you
think that well uh H because she said
this right do you think that no I guess
you're right but it was deemed yeah
forget about what other people say what
do you think what do you think why why
do you think that why do you think that
why do you think that I don't mean to
sound condescending to our liberal
friends they could be otherwise
intelligent people but the vast majority
of them have no idea why they think what
they think they think and in part the
reason for that is they are not required
to analyze their own views in a culture
that is totally dominated by their
fellow Travelers conservatives have to
examine every single one of our views
this is why the conservatives who go to
Liberal colleges tend to have read a
little bit more tend to have thought a
little bit more about their views
because they have to because the
ideological bullets are flying every
single day liberals don't have to do
that at all and the the views that they
think that they hold are extremely
immature and childish and so when you're
when you're in a culture that has been
degraded to the level of two-year-olds
then you need to speak like like a
2-year-old what does a 2-year-old say
why why why why why this why that why
this that's you got to meet people where
they are if you ever want to persuade
them of anything this this has been my
debate style for quite some time now
some debate styles are all about just
totally pummeling the opponent into the
ground that's fun there's there's a time
for that but most of the debates I have
if they're at all in good faith I try to
just persuade people and if you're going
to persuade people you got to kind of
meet them where they are and if you're
going to meet people in this culture
where they are you got to talk like a
2-year-old that's a great question why
do you think that why yeah but why yeah
but why and you get down to First
principles then we figure out if those
first principles are persuasive or not
most of the time they will not be the
rest of the show continues now you do
not want to miss it become a member use
code NES kwes a check out for 2 months
free on all annual
[Music]
plans